we have some type of study described
here I encourage you to pause this video
and think about whether this is an
observational study it's an experiment
or it's a sample study and also think
about whether it was conducted well
alright now let's do this together a
group of doctors was interested in
comparing the effectiveness of placebo
pills and real pills and treating
migraines and placebo pills are pills
that look just like the regular pill and
from a patient's point of view they
don't know which one they're getting and
the reason why we do this in studies is
because there's something called the
placebo effect oftentimes just by taking
things something that you think is good
for you some medicine that you think
might help you it actually does help you
and we can think about why the placebo
effect happens but this is well
documented and so when people are trying
to test medicine they want to say well
does this have an effect above and
beyond the placebo effect and so that's
why they are putting them in these - in
it that's why they're comparing the real
pills to the placebo pills so they
randomly assigned a group of 300
patients suffering from migraines into
two groups so they have their 300 they
have their 300 patients right over here
and they're randomly putting them into
the placebo group placebo group or the
real or the real pill group one group
was given a real pill
we already ready when we are you read
that both groups were told which kind of
pill they got that is sketchy because
the whole point about a placebo is that
you think you got the real thing or you
think you might have gotten the real
thing and if you're told you got a
placebo that tends to undermine the
placebo effect if you're just told
you're giving a a sugar pill well then
the the impact of both no anyway
this this is this is that right over
there is definitely bad practice so
let's let's keep going here before
taking the pills in a day afterwards the
patients were asked to fill out
questionnaires regarding their condition
then the doctors analyze the overall
changes in questionnaires for each group
and compared them all right so first of
all what type of study is this well
we're taking our groups we are randomly
putting them into
two different groups you could call the
placebo group or maybe the the control
group and then you're putting the real
pill as your actual experimental group
and so this is a classic experiment this
is a classic experiment you're trying to
establish a causal relationship you want
to see whether this real pill actually
makes migraines better my migraines
better so does it actually do it and it
does actually do it better than a
placebo and you're randomly putting the
people in both groups to try to
distribute any confounding variables
that there might might be there so this
is clearly an experiment now the other
options you might say well is this maybe
an observational study and remember in
an observational study observationally
that's more of where you look at a
population you look at a group you ask
them a bunch of questions often or you
make a bunch of observations and you see
if there's correlations between two
variables so variable one and variable
two and you're able to make some type of
correlational statement and you're not
trying to get at causality and in a
sample study a sample study this is just
you trying to estimate a parameter for
the entire population so a sample study
might have been of the entire population
what percentage gets migraines and you
don't you can't talk to the entire
population maybe the entire population
is millions of people so you take a
sample of say a hundred people and you
ask them do you get migraines and then
you say okay that percentage of our
sample they get migraines that's a good
estimate for the parameter of what
percentage of my entire population
actually gets migraines so this was
clearly an experiment now the next
question is well that was this
experiment conducted well well even when
I read it I was bothered by both groups
were told which kind of feel they got
that completely defeats the purpose of a
placebo the placebo effect is hey I
think I'm taking something good for me
and it's been documented when you'd
think you're taking a pill that helps
you it oftentimes does help you and so
if someone's coming up with a new
medicine it better be better it better
perform or we it better be more
effective than just that placebo so I
don't like the fact and this is this was
like this is a very bad study to tell
both
groups what kind of pill they got you
actually should tell neither group which
type of pill they got